it man kung fu master
official trailer is here i've seen the
first three hit man movies and i still
don't know if i'm saying it right
man that is how i've said them the whole
time i pee man
i haven't seen the fourth one little
spoiler alert here because i did have it
ruined for me
he dies of old age of cancer so
oh no i feel like this is probably a
prequel i know they did one like many
years ago maybe this is a continuation
of that prequel that's like the safest
assumption
i can make it's ignoring all the sequels
and now it's just the direct
part too they always intend i mean i saw
like on some channel it said it man five
and i'm like that doesn't sound right
so this title it man kung fu master
anyway let's see what's in store have
you seen any of the movies
i've seen many fight scenes from the
movies but i have not seen a complete ip
man movie i
am a heathen and a hater of cinema
alrighty
well let's watch this
he does look like donnie yen
[Music]
a new vision are they just starting over
i wouldn't be surprised
i don't know about that
he also mentored the green hornet it
would only make sense
like triple flashier yeah
i gotta i gotta look this up really
quick to see if this is
a continuation of the prequel or if this
is a remake
because yeah one will leave me a little
bit more upset than the other
okay so according to here he's credited
and the ign description is dennis toe
and he played him
in the legend his board yip man i think
it's yip man it's the correct
pronunciation
just put it down in the comments will
you that came out in 2010
yep man ended with donnie yet
in in the titular role in yip-man four
here's the plot listed on ign yet man
kung fu master
harks back to yip's early days before
the communist revolution in 1949 yet
portrayed by dennis toe for the third
time as the martial artist who famously
tutored bruce lee was then a police
captain who was framed for the murder
of a ruthless but honorable mobster and
targeted for vengeance by his
dangerous daughter forced to quit the
four ships soon also has to contend with
the arrival of the japanese
army and guangzhou
i'm stupid for not knowing how to
pronounce that just getting out of the
way for all you commentators
um all right cool i mean it looks cool
it looks really cool i don't hate it i
mean i'm looking at ign and they have
like 1.2 k likes and 798 that's that's
almost a 50 50
split here i mean it looks a little bit
cheesier
actually looks a lot cheesier looks
goofier whereas like the first one and
at least the trilogy that
the first three that i saw you know it
started off in a pretty
grounded portrayal like the big thing
when they was advertised was this is the
guy who trained bruce lee but that's
really just a side thing
it's not like a focus point of the plot
i don't know if it evolves into that
here it looks like they're going back
really to his early days even
before what took place in there but i'm
kind of wondering if it's going to mess
with the timeline a little bit
because in in the first hitman movie
with donnie yen he's kind of low-key
he's a low-key guy and it looks like
here he would have a major presence
and with the finale ending at least the
tease of the fight to come
guy with his presence who's taking on
the japanese
and it looks like there's going to be a
lot of eyes watching that fight
where in the first movie it was sort of
like who is this guy
and then bam he starts rising up you
know like people in the town knew who he
was but then his legend really comes
into fruition towards the end of that
movie where it looks like here of
it looks like he would have legendary
status by the end of this film right so
that's why i'm kind of getting the
impression
trying to do a little bit of all of it a
soft reboot
prequel kind of rewriting the way some
of it played out
and considering that man four was not
too long ago
to try to revitalize it right away and
right and
just keep it cooking like what i don't
really know i feel about that
yes i have not seen the fourth
installment you know the first three are
still pretty rad and and to me i'm like
you hear it man i think of donnie yen
and this guy looks like donnie yen
i don't know the fights look fun um but
in terms of tampering with a pretty
awesome franchise that made it from a
different country and made it
a game really popular in the states as
well all right
i i kind of get the hate i get it
i mean from an outsider's perspective
looking in on this this
trailer did not fully convince me of the
movie around like the action set pieces
and there were certainly certain moments
that almost reminded me of the raid of
like okay here's gonna be
and i'm sure the other ant-man movies
have like very distinctly themed fights
or whatever
some of that stuff looked appealing but
this almost kind of reminded me of of
that bruce lee movie that came out like
a couple years ago from blumhouse tilt
or whatever
where not that it like stars a white
dude but just something about like the
edges of the production values and stuff
like that
it looks like the fights themselves
would be cool but something about just
the
the the moving itself doesn't look
quite as compelling as like the other
fight scenes i've seen or the trailers
for the previous hit man movies that i
have seen
so i can see at least what you're
getting hat and i do
often find that as a huge pet peeve of
mine with prequel or
earlier set movies when they clearly
depict on the same
timeline somebody who is demonstrating
much crazier more sleek more hollywood
up abilities than we know they will down
the line i really hope that that's not
the case basically for this i mean to me
i'm really just kind of at the confused
state
of even though this guy played him
before the trailer
pitches it as a remake in a lot of ways
they're saying a new vision
of him they're not treating it like a
continuation of the other one so i could
i could see them just straight up
remaking this the wire effects in here
look cool at the same time i'm wondering
how that's going to play with some fans
because while the other movies did have
wire effects in there
it seems like they've kind of amped up a
little bit to make it just
easier to understand a little bit more
like the crouching tiger fantastical
elements and while there is some of that
in the other ones
it looks much more pumped up here in the
trailer especially with the girl it
didn't do a good job even on
it's trying to sell me on a movie here
but not really
the character and i think that's one of
the issues with the trailer too i don't
know exactly what they're trying to
pitch on here just cool action scenes
cool
a cool movie and while i'm sure the
fight scenes will be fine
if you don't have donnie yen in the role
i don't think you should try to like
hide away from that if anything you
should try to be doing something where
you're like you know what it might not
be donnie yen
but this guy's played him before but you
know what
in the end he looks like he'll probably
do a just as good of a job or
at least worthy enough which i i feel
like for some people that's just a no-no
no matter
no matter what they try no matter what
they do it's only donnie yeah
engaged a big part of me kind of feels
that way too
so especially for this version of him i
know it's based on a real life guy but
they
wildly fictionalized franchise yeah
like that that it's tied to donnie and
even in my plebeian minds
yes so like there's other historical
figures you can use i don't know if any
of what they're telling here is grounded
in reality
highly doubt it if it is let me know as
it stands i feel like
for your first debut big trailer or this
i think you could have probably done
a little bit of a better job on actually
selling i'm not going to write it off
entirely because i'm under the
impression that when fight scenes come
up i'll be like
the fights are still cool yeah it just
looks more like a movie than like a
martial arts film
yeah it feels a little bit generic and
especially if you're going to continue
it without donnie ann at least try to
keep this franchise alive you got to
have something that feels a little bit
more unique other than just cool action
well it's a series that seems like it's
innovative
so you can't just borrow from the things
that
if man inspired yeah so have to stay
cutting edge and i think that's a tricky
thing that's just a big you know landing
they got to stick but we'll see how it
turns out
are you guys going to watch it let me
know subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell hit
the like button yadda yadda
deontayw i was thinking about who's
probably the one with the best martial
arts move
over at our patreon page and it's deonte
w
it's called the tongue punch fart box
what he does is he grabs your tongue
punches it so that way you're like and
then he farts in your mouth
just like ass style full-on he's really
flexible double
jointed it's a full-on assault for both
like the physicals
but also it's intoxicating it will pass
out it has
all of the painful senses nasty smell
physical oral pain just like you could
taste it and
that's gross it's just it was just in
his butt you know
his name tongue punch fart box over her
patreon page so we're working with what
we got
guys we're working with what we've got
it's not just some sick thing we came up
with oh it's his fault
this is his nickname and one day we will
find the origin story of that and make
the prequel deonte movie thanks for
being here deontay appreciate you being
part of our patreon page
[Music]
you